the imminent release of matt reeves is
the batman is sending ripples of
excitement through the pop culture realm
the blockbuster is the newest chapter in
gotham cinematic history and marks the
first time since christopher nolan's the
dark knight rises was released in 2012
that the famous caped crusader gets to
appear in his own solo live-action movie
starring robert pattinson is the dark
knight himself the highly anticipated
movie features an incredible cast of
supporting performers that include zoe
kravitz paul dano jeffrey wright john
tutturo peter sarsgaard andy circus and
colin farrell all of whom are playing
iconic characters from dc comics lore in
the batman kravitz for instance is
playing selena kyle aka catwoman in the
film while farrell is set to appear as a
truly iconic bad guy oswald cobblepot
aka the penguin anyone who has seen
reeves previous movies knows that he's
the rare case of a blockbuster filmmaker
who combines spectacle with
thought-provoking storytelling as a
result dc fans are hoping to see him
bring those sensibilities to the batman
as well however it looks like not even a
true auteur like reeves nor any of the
talented cast members he assembled for
the batman are ever truly free of their
studios overlords in fact farrell
recently revealed that while he wanted
to add one quirk he felt would enhance
the character of the penguin and the
batman the powers that be at warner
brothers weren't willing to meet his
small request as variety points out the
batman is a pg-13 rated movie as such
director matt reeves and his
collaborators have to be careful about
how much questionable content they show
on the screen throughout the film now
while it remains to be seen just how
much violence naughty language and
edginess is in the final cut of the
batman parents can rest assured knowing
that according to colin farrell the dc
blockbuster won't inspire their kids to
take up smoking in a recent interview
with jake's takes farrell revealed that
he wanted his version of the penguin to
smoke in the movie as the character
famously does in the comics as well as
in his prior cinematic appearance in tim
burton's batman returns unfortunately
the film's producers weren't willing to
negotiate with a penguin actor despite
his willingness to compromise the actor
recalled i fought valiantly for a cigar
at one stage i said i can have it unlit
just let me have it unlit they were like
no obviously farrell wasn't happy with
the decision at all in fact during the
same interview the batman actor revealed
that he doesn't buy into the idea of
cigarettes and cigars particularly when
smoked by such a villainous character
having a negative impact on younger
viewers farrell remarked as if a bunch
of 12 year olds are going to start
smoking cuban cigars because the penguin
is smoking cigars in a movie colin
farrell may not have been happy about
warner brothers turning down a cigar
request on the batman but that
restriction doesn't seem to have
softened his interpretation of the
penguin in any way not only do the
layers of prosthetic makeup he's wearing
in the film make farrell totally
unrecognizable but early trailers for
the batman have also sold the character
as being a much more grounded criminal
leader than the version played by danny
devito and tim burton's batman returns
consequently farrell's penguin is
shaping up to be much like most of the
characters in the batman a very
different take on a familiar comic book
figure with that in mind the absence of
the penguin's usual cigars only further
separates farrell's cobble pots from
previous incarnations of the character
indeed it's clear that the lack of a
cigar in his mouth didn't stop the actor
from fully embodying his batman
character someone who told movie maker
magazine reminded him of fredo in the
godfather films barrel revealed there's
a certain amount of brokenness in oz
cobblepot that i think as a reference
not for me performance wise but just
emotionally as a reference for matt
reeves i think fredo from the godfather
was a bit of a reference
all this to say that farrell and reeves
clearly didn't let their cigar
concession stop them from bringing to
life a version of the penguin that dc
comics fans have never really seen on
the big screen before of course whether
or not beryl's penguin is received well
by comic book readers remains to be seen
the batman hits theaters on march 4th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite dc movies and shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]